we understood from the very beginning
that if we want to be
big if we want to be market leaders if
we want to conquer the market and this
was the vision of the
of the company from day one we have to
be a standard
and this is why we formed this
organization that is called the hdbc
alliance we formed
we formed it together with sony samsung
and lg so we had
great partners that supported us and
loved our technology
and um i can tell you that in a matter
of years
we really changed the face of the
professional audio video market
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20-minute
leaders this is the story
of how an israeli company changed the
way
high-tech companies around the world are
perceiving their own technology
and creating a standard that everybody
else wants to follow
meet donna zelitsky vice president of
marketing advance
with more than 10 years of experience in
the high-tech industry in various
business development marketing and
product management roles
dyna is responsible for the valence's
marketing activities
dana leads the company's messaging
positioning go-to-market and general
marketing activities
including communications trade shows
media digital marketing and more
dan has contributed to building the
valance and hdbaset brands
and establishing the company's
leadership in both the audio video
and automotive markets donna zolitsky
welcome to 20 minute leaders all the way
from valence how are you
i'm doing great hi michael thanks for
having me
thank you very very much for for being
here spending 10 years at valance
uh it's a it's a long journey and i'm
excited to to dig deep into
into what what this company is all about
semiconductors automotives audio video
connectivity
you're going to tell me much more so
that
you know so that i can actually
understand you know this world but then
i also want to talk a little bit about
the role of marketing in such a company
the role of marketing semiconductors and
and in a really deep technology because
it's not the same as building a brand
for for the traditional consumers so so
donna tell me a little bit about your
entrance to violence
and what you guys are doing okay so
um so as you said i've been in balance
for 10 years so
uh it's been a very long time ago and
vance was a completely different company
um at the time i did not come from the
marketing world
at all at the time but i've learned a
lot about marketing since uh since i've
joined
um i've joined violence when we were
about
20 people in valence and valence had
um an idea already when it was founded
to turn its unique technology called
hdbasd
into an industry standard by the way
this is something that
is a real value for us and a successful
go-to-market approach for valence
ever since we started and we do it in
every market
we operate so i actually joined the
lands
to do exactly that and to lead um
an organization that is called hdbst
alliance that exists or
exists today today it has over 200
member companies
and um to bring more and more companies
into this alliance and
create an industry standard um
i want to i want to dig deeper into
exactly this topic
creating an industry standard as a
strategy
for for a go to market what what does
that mean
to you why why is you know what what is
sort of the thinking behind that and
what have you been what have you learned
over over the years what's the reasoning
behind it that's a great question so
first of all
to to understand that you need to
understand that we are in the
communication business
so our technology in a nutshell i can go
on and on about it but we don't have
much time
um is a very unique technology for
high-speed communications
especially when there is a need for very
high quality video
without any latency and over a very
simple long distance wiring
infrastructure
that's in a nutshell so we started in
the audio video business
where you have a lot of standards
communication protocols
one good example would be hdmi which is
a widely
commonly used standard for consumer
electronics
um so obviously if you want to connect
your tv
to to whatever device uh you have on the
other end
with hdmi and your tvs from lg and the
other devices from
another vendor it has to be a standard
and they all have to speak the same
language
so for less when we approached uh
we started in the professional audio
video market very high-end audio video
devices
we understood from the very beginning
that if we want to be
big if we want to be market leaders if
we want to conquer the market and this
was the vision of the of the company
from day one
we have to be a standard and
this is why we formed this organization
that is called the hdbc alliance
we formed we formed it together with
sony samsung and lg so we had great
partners that supported us and loved our
technology
and i can tell you that in a matter of
years we really changed the face
of the professional audio video market
by turning it to a market that usually
works with closed system
end-to-end systems from the same vendor
to an open market
with a real industry standard and we
were really
embraced uh by the end users of
of this industry so this is the
reasoning and um
we do it also in other industries that
we operate
today in automotive and others as well
so obviously this is very very special
you know i mean you're you're talking
about
a strategy for for acquiring market
leadership
through creating this this you know um
standardization that allows the the
these audio video communications to to
to work throughout through the various
vendors and obviously you're doing a big
service to the competitive market and
allowing many more players to come and
interact with each other which is at the
end how you know even we're doing
this show right now tell me a little bit
about the early days of it because
you know i'm imagining a comp an israeli
company coming and trying to say
we're going to create an industry
standard for audio video communication
that can't be an easy feat to complete
right and that's actually a great story
because this is also how
i find myself doing marketing because
that's the only thing i had to do
at the time so so i joined valence with
the purpose of leading the hdbc alliance
and bringing more and more companies on
board
um and and it was it was a really
difficult task
i didn't realize that when i joined but
uh about
uh three four months after joining
valencia i said oh my god what did i do
to myself i'm never going to succeed
with this uh with this crazy task we're
a small company we just
taped out our first chipset um
and i need to go to huge companies and
tell them
not only you need to buy the chipset
from us you need to pay annual
membership fees to this alliance
that no one heard of uh and not only
that you need to start
talking with other vendors and open your
systems and change the way you used to
work
it's almost like selling to an exclusive
club right
yeah that's one way of looking at it
that's that's uh that's a great pitch
but i didn't work all the time so um
i had some tough calls and then um i
didn't have much
choice but to start doing marketing
and luckily for us we had uh we still do
but we had a great technology
that the end users of our technology
really needed
um we saw the real pain point for the
audio video
installers audio video integrators um
which are basically the customers of our
customers
so we really started doing marketing we
um which which is almost like a b2c
marketing in
in that case we created uh training
programs a lot of market education
um we created a compliance program a
certification program in the alliance
that would enable members to put the our
logo
on their devices and i remember one of
the first campaigns that we did was
look for the logo wow and it was a
campaign
that the target audience were not our
customers they were the end users
and it worked it created demand it
created a bad
uh uh market and we were able to
to to turn uh to turn it really uh into
a standard and bring more and more
members on
and then the pitch of a closed
membership club actually
into a standard available also how i
found myself doing marketing for this
standard and for violence
um which wasn't my intention in the
first place
you know we're talking at the end of it
an israeli company from
a a country back then i guess about 7
million
people talk creating an industry
standard worldwide with some of the
biggest companies in the world did that
did that ever
you know bring any challenges with it
that you know coming from israel all of
a sudden coming and trying to
you know even i i'm even trying to
imagine this the
the campaign of look for the logo i mean
that's really really cool this idea that
you know the israeli logo is an
industry standard across these devices
right so actually um at the time
we it's not where we never hit the fact
that we're a small
israeli company but this is this was
also one of the reasons why we relied on
the alliance brand it's called the hdb
hdbc alliance
on the hdbc brand because then we had
brand names
such as sony samsung and lg who had
strong interest to promote our
technology and
really um we relied on this brand on
all of our marketing activities and all
on all of our education activities
uh to the market and we still do for
violence audio video
um we still leave this today a
successful alliance with a lot of
members on board
and a great ecosystem but i can tell you
that this is a challenge that we
we always have and we feel it even um
strongly much more strongly in the
automotive business
so a few years uh um about six years ago
we
were looking for the next big market for
balance and next growth opportunity
and we realized that we have a very
unique opportunity in the automotive
market
we adjusted our technology there was a
very
crucial need for a high-speed
communication
inside the vehicle okay there's a lot of
talk about
uh vehicle to vehicle communication
or vehicle to the cloud communication
balance focuses on okay you have all
these sensors riders sliders that
you have a lot of video coming into the
car
that has to to be sent and processed
by the the head unit of the car without
any latency
and in real time and over a very simple
infrastructure with high reliability
it's
very complicated environment for
high-speed communication and we are a
perfect fit
for that uh for that need um so we moved
into
the automotive market which if you
compare it to the audio video consumer
electronic world is a much more
conservative
industry they have much more concerns
to to bet or to risk by going on a small
going um with a small israeli company
like balance especially in such
in technology like ours that is really
the infrastructure
of connectivity for the car it's not an
add-on it's not a nice feature that if
the company closes
uh a year after they can easily they can
easily change
when when when we get a customer we are
there to stay for
for many years um and and they are aware
of it and they are concerned
um uh about it or at least they were
concerned
um what helped us i think um
were three things three main things in
that respect
the first one was the incredible um
momentum uh or the incredible growth
of the local auto tech industry
uh in general uh before covid
we had allegations from uh car
manufacturers or from other leaders in
the in the automotive world coming into
israel basically every week
um there was such a um
a boom uh in uh israel
tech companies selling for automotive
and we really enjoyed it
so all eyes were on the israeli auto
tech
community which was great um second
thing that helped us
was really uh that we were lucky enough
to get a first customer very quickly
and not and a very
uh prestigious customer we are today i
can proudly say that we are already
um on the road in mercedes s class
uh adam mercedes models um
um we we're very we're very proud of it
and we have we're very happy to tell
uh the world about it and we work
closely
with dynamo mercedes um on future
projects as well so that's so that's
great
um and the third thing that helps us and
that helps us and
going back to the standard uh approach
is
that we already um
were used to the to the idea of setting
industry
standards we knew how to operate it
we quickly teamed with
an established standard organization
that is called the mepi alliance
that opened a working group to
standardize
high-speed video connectivity um and
um very quickly we engaged with them
they
evaluated our technology they tested our
technology in comparison to other
technologies and
decided to develop their new automotive
standard
based uh on our solution
on our technology so that was an
incredible
uh achievement for us both from a
business perspective
and a technological perspective but
mainly gave a validation
for our technology from such a leading
industry standard that really reassured
all of the oems and the major um players
in the industry
that balance yeah what did you take with
you
from you know it almost sounds like it's
you know two different you know journeys
you know you had the journey through the
other video and then entering the
automotive but and
as vp of marketing what did you take
with you from
the first journey that you know you kept
with you and you made perhaps some
things that you didn't keep with you
as you now approached a much more
conservative robust
uh with with a lot with you know really
heavy incumbents
yeah i think maybe it's not to be
conservative
in the way we do marketing i think
that's uh
like that's what i that's what i was
used to doing because i was basically
doing marketing for the end users for
the consumers
when when we were doing uh when we were
working only on a video
um so we were used to being a little bit
disruptive in our in our marketing
and i think we brought that with us um
also to automotive and we did some
fun campaigns great campaigns that
everyone was a big
concern in the beginning and looked at
us a little dramatically
uh but it did it did the effect that we
needed and uh we did a lot of noise
in the industry uh um when we joined as
newcomers
and and this is what we wanted to
achieve i mean our competition are
huge semiconductor players and we had to
if you're not disruptive you're not
going to be and so the previous brand
that you've already built
for balance that i guess that played a
pretty big role in also setting
setting the trust and the momentum from
the get-go right
yes i think also the validation that
balance is accompanied
is used to work already with industry
giants such as panasonic and
exxon and samsung and lg it really
helped us
also in terms of validation and also in
terms of our operations
uh uh procedures and our ability to
deliver
uh in such a demanding industry like
like the automotive and for such a
demanding
customer in your role you have to really
understand
both the the technology aspect and you
really have to understand you know
what's happening there because
at the end is you're selling this and as
you're marketing this to the world
whether it's the
the end consumers or whether it's the
you know the
the buyers from from these large
companies how do you balance
you know both the diving deep and really
understanding the details versus
you know maintaining 30 000 feet in the
air and being able to understand the
landscape of the market
yeah so um it's not easy
i have uh actually a semi-technical
background i uh
i i have a business
math and computer science so i thought i
thought it would be a piece of cake for
me
but it's not i mean uh uh
working with engine with vlsi engineers
and
talking uh uh dsp all day it's not
something that
i'm used to but i've learned along the
years how to
to filter out what's not needed for me
and and you know focus on what's
important
and i think most importantly you have to
be
a non-technical person to be able to to
translate it
into something that the general audience
would understand
and in marketing we talk we talk
benefits
so i always cut to the chase you know
when i stick with an engineer i always
you know when he goes a little bit with
me i cut in the chain
and and everyone else to talk benefits
as well because i don't know no no i i
love that
donna i really want to thank you for
taking the time to come and chat with me
about violence i have a few questions
about you
and we started getting to know a little
bit you in the in this last bit but
i want to take you back now to your
childhood what was something that
fascinated you as a kid whether it's a
passion hobby
or or a favorite subject in school what
really
what really made you interested
so that's a strange mix because i was i
had a lot of artistic inspirations when
i was a child
i was actually going to the school of
arts uh learning to be a ballerina
amazing um but uh
quickly enough i understood that that i
don't have a future there i remember my
uh
my classic ballet teacher told me relax
enjoy it this is not math
and i used to tell her i wish it was
math because math is so much uh
is so much more easier for me and
uh and more fun so it was like a weird
balance
who is somebody that perhaps inspires
you along your either personal or
professional journey
you know in one way shape or form not
necessarily the role model but somebody
that inspires you
yeah i don't feel like i can name a
specific person and i know we're running
out of time we didn't talk about
um um the feminist aspect
or about being a woman um in high tech
uh and in such a uh um
manly environment um and i guess if you
talk to me a few years ago
i wouldn't even make an issue out of it
but i've learned in time that it does
put
different challenges on you uh um so i
look
at a lot of women as role models
in tech and in general and they're wrong
i don't want to name a speaking person
but it's definitely something
i always look
especially when you're talking about
deep technology and when you're talking
about things that that
you know that are that are more stem
oriented and and i think that
you know the example that you're that
you're here i think it's i think it's
very inspiring at least
and i'm sure to many many others and
last question three words that you would
use to describe
yourself
someone that really hates these kind of
questions
but i guess um
non-committing yeah oh that's that
that's strange for someone that has been
10 years in the same place um and
married for uh
for her uh boyfriend since the age of
20. but um
amazing yeah thank you very very much
uh stay safe stay safe and stay up thank
you for joining me
take care bye
[Music]